the the next the next topic is the
update on the Logan uh Paul fight so as
you guys know we've been talking about
Logan and Dylan Dan is on this channel
they have a fight coming up in October
and all week Dylan has just been
tweeting
oh God picture after picture after
picture of Logan Paul's fiance and guys
it has been breaking the internet I want
to know what this man is gonna make off
of his Twitter ad Revenue this month
because it has to be insane there there
is no way this man doesn't make at least
ten thousand dollars just off of
the pictures that he has put up of of
Logan's fiance now Logan has I think
said some of the pictures are fake you
know which some probably are
but I don't know all 75
like that's a lot that's a lot that's a
lot of pictures that that is a lot of
pictures so
you know Logan and Dylan met at the
press conference this week and here is
some footage from the press conference
so yeah if you show up stupid yeah I'm
not sure oh don't worry just like it's
just like Nina showed up to every guy's
house hey man hey it's your birthday
right yeah it is 30th birthday yeah
y'all I got Dylan again oh yeah let me
tell you my friend we don't really
descend to the table if you know what's
good for you you don't want to start to
Riot don't start throwing cakes about
down here don't start throwing cakes
about me John John I have no arm I'm not
a baseball
no cakes being choked
happy birthday to you
you [__] little [__] ass [__] who
doesn't show up to any fights ever I got
a cake of you getting knocked out with
the camel toe happy birthday to you you
[__] [__]
don't want your boyfriend step up for
you huh take that [__] out on me cause
my brother hooked up with your ex
at least I got rid of this song You're
marrying one
apartment costs more than your entire
network
bro
if Dylan thinks a single photo he's
posted has rattled me at all he's a
dumbass imagine being Logan Paul with
hundreds and millions of dollars in the
bank account and out of all the girls he
could have been with he chose to marry a
model who has a higher body count than
Genghis Khan that is a true definition
of a disciple of the soy a super cooked
man a beta male soy Drinker and when
Logan Paul was asked about his crypto
scam why would I take my Million Dollar
Bet why won't you pay back to people
from crypto Zoo I'm working on it Dylan
I'm working on it Dylan meanwhile Logan
Paul goes out and spends five hundred
thousand dollars on a ring for a fiance
who has cooked him what about the
innocent people he scammed it doesn't
seem like he's working on it I just
think that Logan has and now seeing how
he's taking this personal stuff like his
mind is not there what have you heard
from them on their end zone has put a
little bit of a trap on me but there's
definitely trouble in Paradise I'm not
gonna lie I was like gonna praise him
because like you know I'm all about like
trans and like lgbtq and everything so I
was gonna be like oh it's awesome he
like has a fiance that's trans so I
thought she was and then I looked it up
and it was a girl and then I started
seeing all the stuff so I was like oh
she's she's gorgeous though do you feel
bad for her do you think it's like like
how do you think it's affecting her dick
did this to me I don't know if you
remember when me and him were gonna
fight when he was saying that he was
going out my girl he was saying he
[__] her this whole thing so like it's
a double-edged sword like you can't talk
all that [__] and not be able to take it
that's the worst kind of person wow
I I think we're gonna keep seeing this
as a trend of
you know men men sort of getting roasted
for for the chicks that they marry you
know it's funny I 10 20 years ago men
didn't really get roasted like that
um for marrying chicks not this bad like
you saw
Kanye Mary Kim Kardashian and I I there
was a bit of Fallout I remember but it
was it it certainly was not this oh my
gosh you know what I you know what I
just realized if you want to make money
women we just always tend to make the
wrong decision so you invest in anything
that like helps us take back bad
decisions like we're fat so you invest
in bbls we post damn near everything for
attention and then we want to take it
back later so if you invest in any like
internet scrubbing
and you know what I mean like internet
scrubbing software I I bet you I bet you
you make a lot of money like instead of
instead of like box wine and cat food
and dog food invest in like anything
that makes women's bad decisions
disappear
yeah or makes us look younger forever
Okay so
yeah essentially we're gonna we're gonna
keep seeing this I I thought
I really wish Logan brought some better
roasts so I really was hoping that he
would
that he would roast him a bit better do
you guys think if Logan wins this fight
that they can't roast him anymore
because honestly I don't even think
whoever wins the fight matters because
he's just so far gone right now
but okay yeah that's the updates on the
Logan Paul fight